[Música]
yo llevo 21 años trabajando en el mundo
de los medios comencé en un medio
digital en el año 97
que se llamaba latino net del grupo
bavaria valorem en ese momento
escribiendo contenido para digital
cuando quería cambiarle el color o el
puntaje a un título o poner un color
algo me tenía que meter el código html y
tirar código no existía en los cms los
productos los los editores de contenido
web
y así comenzó así comenzó mi rol en los
medios de comunicación
siempre he hablado de transformación
digital disrupción digital storytelling
la cantidad de discursos alrededor de
este tema de transformación digital de
los medios pero hoy lo único que se me
ocurrió
hoy
ok
es venir a hacer un mea culpa hoy quiero
delante de ustedes como periodista
dentro de la industria de los medios de
comunicación hacer un mea culpa un mea
culpa porque bueno sabemos es que mea
culpa es una palabra del latín que tiene
que ver con yo pecador dentro del rito
romano litúrgico de darse golpes de
pecho saben ustedes que el pecado está
en el corazón decían las sagradas
escrituras
por eso golpearse el corazón era
sacudirse lo quitárselo para que llegase
dios y lo tomar el 'mea culpa' que yo
quiero hacer hoy delante de ustedes es
como siendo un testigo de lo que ha
venido pasando hoy en día todavía no
encontramos el verraco camino para salir
adelante los medios de comunicación en
la disrupción digital no lo hemos
encontrado después de más de 12 o 13
años en que nos cayó esta o la
disrupción por eso hay que hacer una
mirar mirar hacia atrás más mirar hacia
hacia atrás
en ustedes porque los retrovisores son
más pequeños que los panorámicos
el pasado es importante y uno tiene que
verlo pero lo importante es lo que viene
hacia adelante
no hay que fincar más en el pasado sino
en lo que está hacia delante lo que nos
viene hacia adelante por eso mismo hoy
quiero contarles que los medios de
comunicación en algún momento fuimos
un gran baile de un salón
nosotros éramos el hombre nuestra
audiencia era la mujer y la maneja vamos
a nuestro antojo poníamos la canción que
queríamos cambiamos el ritmo y realmente
ni siquiera la escuchábamos si estaba
cómoda si le gustaba lo que estaba
bailando si tal vez quería descansar o
escuchar otra canción
éramos absolutamente los dueños del
salón de baile los que poníamos el ritmo
pero un día
nos cayó esta ola digital de disrupción
que si bien arrancó con la música la
fotografía
el alquiler de películas por allá en los
años la medida de los 90 a comienzos del
2010 le cae a los medios de comunicación
esta disrupción digital viene este gran
cambio entre internet de nuestro negocio
de manera muy potente y
nos cambian
la canción nos cambiaron el baile nos
quitaron la pareja y nos cambiaron la
canción
y lo peor de todo es que entregamos a
nuestra pareja felices cedimos a nuestra
pareja con total felicidad a este nuevo
modelo disruptivo digital porque felices
lo hicimos primero porque entendimos en
su momento que eso era un canal muy un
facilitador gratuito
están haciéndolo bien
no nos cobran nada nos dejan poner
nuestro contenido ahí porque al no
hacerlo nos están facilitando las cosas
2 a 1 y todavía pero en esa época tal
vez tendría algo de asidero creíamos que
era la misma audiencia comprendíamos a
nuestros televidentes oyentes y lectores
como los mismos que nos estaban
consumiendo en internet y tal vez en esa
época si fue así hoy en día el negocio
es otro y es otra la situación ojo
porque no vamos a satanizar a las redes
sociales aquí es una estupidez decir que
las redes sociales tienen la culpa o que
es un problema tecnológico que va en
contra de los medios de comunicación no
evidentemente nos enseñaron cosas muy
potentes y siguen siendo hoy en día un
faro muy importante en la aproximación a
las audiencias pero en esa época además
creíamos que nos estábamos ahorrando un
montón de plata y de tener que aprender
cosas que no eran naturales en nuestro
modelo de negocio para que aprender de
data para que aprender de big data para
que aprender de tecnología para que
aprender de algoritmos si ya había
alguien que lo estaba haciendo y lo
estaba haciendo gratis
dejando usar sin ningún problema
perfecto funcionaba muy bien el tema
todos íbamos muy bien hasta que un día
yo trabajaba en una casa editorial muy
grande
en el año 2016 un día llegué a trabajar
suelta mis morral me senté y encontrar a
toda mi redacción digital pálida con
esta cara había caído el tráfico de ese
periódico en digital el 75% de un día
para otro cayó el tráfico el 75% por
completo
nos dimos cuenta que esta fuente de
tráfico azul
dejó de darnos tráfico de un día para
otro creíamos que era un error nuestro
empezamos a mover la máquina por detrás
que está pasando los conectamos mal
llamamos a esta empresa decirle venga
algo pasó con ustedes ayúdenos auxilio
se nos cayó el tráfico que nos dan que
hacemos ellos hacia la misma cara que
nosotros ningún en serio se les cayó
porque es tan largo al final de vitoria
descubrimos que estaban lanzando y
estaban probando facebook instance
articles es decir entendimos
había una cosa que se llamaba algoritmo
y había una cosa que hacía el algoritmo
y era cambiar completamente la regla de
juego de aproximaciones a audiencia es
decir ya no estábamos no solamente
bailando con nuestra audiencia sino que
ahora alguien en la mitad nos decía qué
canción bailar a qué horas y si no
quería que esa persona bailará con
nosotros pues no la ponía a bailar con
nosotros y nos escondía
nos dijeron en ese momento que el
contenido es el rey y nos quedamos en
cuenta evidentemente el contenido es el
rey es muy importante lo que nunca nos
dijeron es que la distribución es la
reina
y ahí está el gran la gran columna
vertebral de lo que quiero contarles hoy
y del mensaje que les quiero dejar hoy
en esta charla muy corta
porque entender esto de que significa el
algoritmo fue un gran proceso muy largo
hoy en día junto con la fórmula de la
coca-cola está esta vaina
nadie sabe cómo funciona cómo opera cómo
se configura y cómo debemos reaccionar
ante el algoritmo de todas las redes
sociales es un tema bien complejo que
nos sigue dando mucho esfuerzo que nos
sigue generando mucho dolor de cabeza y
nos genera aún más un reto muy
importante ya les voy a contar por qué
además comprendimos esta tremenda frase
data llama plata
la data es muy importante y si bien ese
vehículo tradicional que nosotros
teníamos no nos importaba no nos
importaba si era efectivo o no si la
gente lo consumía o no que pensaba
cuando llegaba con ese contenido
recuérdese que bailábamos en un gran
salón y no ni siquiera le mirábamos la
cara a nuestra pareja en digital la cosa
cambió completamente se vuelve esto un
proceso mucho más interactivo nacen los
prosumidores ya nuestra audiencia nos
dice en la cara ustedes no se imaginan
el momento en el que uno escribe un
artículo de algo y alguien levanta la
mano y le dice eres un total idiota
por lo que acabas de escribir porque esa
persona sabe más que yo y tiene mucho
argumento para rebatir lo que yo estoy
diciendo nace este proceso tan complejo
de entender la data de entender la
interacción de entender cómo a partir de
esa aproximación a la audiencia puede
ser mucho más rico el crecimiento de los
medios de comunicación y les insisto no
estoy satanizando las redes simplemente
es dejándoles en claro que hoy en día no
entendemos no entendemos cómo funciona
esto y lo debo decir con total
de manera muy descarnada no va a cambiar
hasta que no nos muramos
todos toda esta generación de
periodistas que nacieron en el
periodismo tradicional esto no va a
cambiar va a ser muy difícil
datos muy sencillos el 92% de los
usuarios en colombia gastar más o menos
4 ó 5 horas diarias en redes sociales y
adivine qué hacen las redes sociales en
un 40 y en un 54 por ciento consumir
contenido noticioso consumir medios de
comunicación consumen mi contenido
van a las redes sociales a consumir el
contenido todavía el rol de la marca se
mantiene por ahí cuando algo pasa hay
una noticia hay una marcha hay una algo
de última hora la gente todavía acude al
medio de comunicación porque es un
validador de lo que está pasando pero ya
no somos nosotros el front de cara a la
audiencia les puedo decir en los medios
que trabajado
el tráfico proveniente de esa gran red
social y del buscador puede sumar entre
ambos más del 80 por ciento del tráfico
más del 80 por ciento de la aproximación
en la audiencia es decir que estamos
totalmente a merced de lo que los
algoritmos de estos intermediarios
tengan de poner o no nuestro contenido
de valorar o no nuestro contenido y de
cambiar constantemente esas reglas de
juego la gente que acs o
que optimiza el contenido para que
aparezca bien o bien o que sepa jugar
con los algoritmos es gente que está
llegando a un nivel de valoración y de
importancia y relevancia los medios de
comunicación altísimos son personas muy
importantes en el desarrollo de nuestra
labor
qué reto no se está imponiendo
fuertemente esta intermediación esta
distribución el primero tiene que ver el
call to action con el engagement hoy en
día estamos absolutamente relegados al
ct es decir cómo podemos titular o hacer
contenidos que despiertan algún tipo de
interacción y de interacción estoy
hablando de sentimientos y cuando
hablamos de sentimientos estamos
hablando de viralidad es decir cómo
logramos indignar a la gente molesta
hacer que se pongan muy bravos para que
hagan algo porque esos indicadores algo
me dicen porque entre otras cosas esa
intermediación además de que está
bailando con mi pareja le está diciendo
cosas al oído que yo no sé qué le está
diciendo y esa pareja le responde cosas
al oído hay una data de interacción que
yo desconozco por completo
el engagement que es el gran valor es
esa relación emocional directa de valor
con la marca se la reservan ellos ya no
la comparto yo la tienen completamente
tomada y la están monetizando de manera
muy efectiva que otros retornos imponen
la intermediación nos ha impuesto la
monetización
engagement da plata 7 a da centavos
centavitos de dólar entonces estamos en
una relación tal vez del 10 del 10 por
ciento de la torta de publicidad digital
en colombia estamos metidos ciento y
punta de medios digitales peleándonos
ese poquito de plata que nos deja la
vitalidad la interacción
la gran plata la data
el poder comprender el behavioral
journey de los usuarios el poder prever
que van a hacer y sobre eso a tomar
acciones comerciales no lo estamos
haciendo está exclusivo o lo mante lo
maneja exclusivamente la intermediación
también estamos tratando de quien no se
nos diluya la marca quienes conocen tick
tock
han visto alguna es una marca de medio
de comunicación en texto
quien es bueno quienes tienen en su
carro ya ondas que tú tienes un mercedes
pero quien tiene un dashboard ya ios y
android auto en sucre en su carro
ven alguna marca de medio de
comunicación en este taller táctil
estamos rogando el adiós no perder
nuestra presencia de marca y hoy en día
los chicos no conocen las marcas de
medios de comunicación no las conocen
porque interactuar con marcas no es
natural en las redes sociales la gente
interactúa con caras con nombres y
apellidos por eso me voy a ir un poquito
hacia delante está el tema de la
polarización los periodistas están
tomando cada vez más relevancia versus
la marca el día que daniel samper se fue
de perdón que daniel coronell dijo que
sacaba su columna de semana ese día yo
me preocupé un montón
yo dije se sobreviene la muerte los
medios de comunicación porque el hecho
de que hayamos perdido nuestra pareja es
un tema muy complejo tenemos que ver
cómo la recuperamos pero el hecho de que
los que hacen el contenido se den cuenta
que tampoco necesitan el medio y pueden
hacerlo a un lado para interactuar
derecho con la pareja como pensaba
hacerlo en el coro en el que se murieron
al mes de expulsión apaga y vámonos
porque los periodistas están tomando
cada vez más presencia fuerte en nuestra
interacción digital pero lo están
haciendo como
con mucha emocionalidad entonces están
tomando partido y los están atacando
ellos están defendiendo y eso está
afectando a las marcas de medios y
estamos además tratando de recuperar
nuestra pareja y tratando de calmar a
una columnista o dos columnistas que
están agarrados del tiempo con la parte
digital entonces hay un brand de safety
y los clientes ya no quieren pautar en
un sitio donde estamos agarrados todos
los días con la audiencia
para que vayan entendiendo cómo se está
moviendo este tema y estamos además en
un partido es igual estamos jugando en
una cancha que está así
en donde acá abajo están nuestros
competidores digitales y nosotros
estamos más arriba para que ustedes
hagan una idea en el negocio de
televisión tenemos que cumplir más de
100 regulaciones distintas cuota de
pantalla
tenemos que entregarle plata a un fondo
de televisión tenemos de según la
facturación que tenemos tenemos que
contratar talento colombiano tenemos que
cuidar el lenguaje los horarios para que
los tablet abramos a los niños o no
ustedes creen que ellos cumplen siquiera
algo de eso no lo cumplen absolutamente
no hay un partido muy desigual también
que es una preocupación que está muy
clara y está pasando entre muchas
industrias porque además en este caso en
el caso nuestro esta intermediación
tiene ese componente de desigualdad hay
otra intermediación la música el cine
los eventos deportivos y demás que si
están recibiendo el costo o el valor de
su contenido ya está la gran
preocupación entonces
qué vamos a hacer
primero que todo prepararnos para lo que
viene
en lo cual somos muy buenos hay que
decirlo es decir muy pocos medios muy
pocas casas editoriales están pensando
en la cuarta revolución industrial en
inteligencia artificial en las nuevas
redes que vienen los momentos de consumo
nuevos los dispositivos que están
llegando ayotte y robótica en fin
machine learning y demás estamos muy
todavía demorados para poder entrar ahí
pero si alguna vez en algún momento nos
ponemos en ese plan de entrarle fuerte a
la cuarta revolución industrial yo creo
que vamos a poder recortar un poco esa
pelea que tenemos con las grandes redes
sociales
lo segundo tenemos que bailar juntos no
existe no existe industria más
y desagregada más atomizada
más poco alineada que la de medios de
comunicación se los digo yo he intentado
en muchas mesas en muchos gremios de
alinear algunas cosas que pongámonos de
acuerdo aquí venga tratemos de pensar en
un tema tarifan no no porque entonces
cartelización no porque nos vamos a
meter un problema prepararme en el vídeo
por favor entonces estamos en esa
discusión
constante de competencia que nos
preocupamos luchamos por que pasen cosas
de manera individual escondiendo
información cuando si quieres poner
vídeo por favor
cuando al otro lado están absolutamente
alineados perfectamente organizados
entonces hagan de cuenta que estos somos
los medios de comunicación
así nos vemos
tenía lo
qué sincronía
mientras facebook instagram whatsapp
google
están perfectamente sincronizados en
tarifas en tendencias en innovación en
desarrollo y aquí estamos ahora con el
tiempo del retador semana y aquí están
facebook
instagram está perfectamente alineados
gracias tenemos que volver a bailar
juntos tenemos que unirnos como
industria tenemos que comprender que si
no nos unimos y no trabajamos por lo
menos con tres o cuatro puntos
transversales en un horizonte claro nos
vamos a morir los que van a matar a los
medios de comunicación somos nosotros
mismos y nuestra desunión que más
tenemos que hacer por favor con la
presentación
gracias
después de bailar juntos tenemos que
lograr nivelar la regla de juego
definitivamente esto no esto es un
clamor no solamente de esta industria de
medios usted ha escuchado este clamor en
muchas otras industrias es urgente
trabajar por que los medios de
comunicación logren un ecosistema sano y
equilibrado de trabajo no vamos a lograr
cosa distinta a ver cada vez más
titulares de medios despidiendo gente
cerrando ediciones acabando con el grupo
se enteró de trabajo no va a ser
distinto si no logramos nivelar la regla
de juego para que de cierta manera estas
personas los medios de comunicación que
son los encargados de construir la
cultura de una nación las redes sociales
no construyen cultura los medios de
comunicación si construyen cultura
cultura de su dimensión global pues no
no existe la manera de poder ayudarlos
y segundo volver a lo básico perdón
tercero volver a lo básico hay un
concepto que se llama describirse cuando
no lo tuvieran que ver la misma noticia
es como cuando no le chupan en la
chupeta en el de la botella al pro otro
ya no me interesa pero qué pasa cuando
el mecha y vean yo tengo que salir 23
pasos adelante luego entonces si
entramos fuertemente en este modelo de
cuarta revolución industrial entendiendo
como integramos apropiamos las
tecnologías como impulsamos un trabajo
gremial fuerte unificado para nivelar
las reglas de juego podemos salir más
adelante de chivear nos porque
evidentemente el contenido sigue siendo
el rey' y finalmente tenemos que lograr
que el rey tome la reina nuevamente de
la cintura y vuelvan a bailar juntos de
manera cadenciosa esta es la información
que les traía hoy muchas gracias así que
seguiremos conversando
[Aplausos]
[Música]